i've had pretty middling
experiences with wireless headphones in
the past but
i think i finally found a set that suits
this
irregular sized cranium so why do i
think
the steel series arctis 9 are finally
the wireless headphones for me i mean
firstly
they look great they're clean simple
they've got this nice matte finish to
them
the steel frames sturdy while being
lights
but because they're not overly
gamery i feel like i can actually
wear these away from my desk if i want
to go for a walk
or other shops and not have little timmy
point and look and be like oh look
there's a nerd let's get him and if i
want to get away from my desk i can even
hide the microphone
inside the ear cup so this point
they're just a nice set of earphones
like i said the steel frame makes them
extremely durable
lightweight flexible to the point that
paired with the ski goggle headband that
steel series use even on my
giant head they're perfectly comfortable
so if you have a human sized head
and you're not some kind of missing
evolution link like i am
chances are they're gonna be a great fit
for you as well i'm also a huge fan
of the breathable ear cups that steel
series use
none of that fake plastic leather
sort of thing that gets real sweaty when
your room is anything
above like 20 degrees celsius and if you
have headphones for too long they start
flaking off and
falling apart no no no no no nice and
breathable
nice and comfortable feels great against
my skin i've been wearing these for
six to ten hours a day for the past 5
days and
i have not had a single complaint or
felt discomfort
even once but headphones aside for a
second the other feature that comes in
the box
is the steelseries wireless hub this is
probably
it probably makes one of my favorite
features of the whole
kit that you get now steelseries claims
that this thing has a range of
40 feet using its 2.4 gigahertz wireless
connection
i haven't been walking around with a
tape measure i must admit but i have
been able to go to every room in my
house and venture forth with into the
garden without
any quality drop or any signals cutting
out
whatsoever so for normal
everyday use this thing is probably
going to go above and beyond what you
want it to do
but you also have the option of using
the 2.4 gigahertz wireless connection
in tandem with the bluetooth capability
of the headphones that means for if if
for some bizarre reason you want to wear
these
listen to your game audio and your
discord audio but also
play music through your phone to the
headphones
you can do that i don't know really why
you'd want to do that that sounds like a
bit of a
cacophony to me but hey it's nice to
have options
but for me the best quality of life that
dongle gives you as opposed to
standard wireless headphones that just
come on a usb
is that the hub features audio in and
out
now that means you can use your computer
speakers
in tandem with the wireless headphones
and what i mean by that
is that as soon as you turn the
headphones on
your computer audio will switch from
speaker
to headphones and vice versa as soon as
you turn them off
back to speakers and it's doing all that
without you having to
suffer and like oh go down i need to go
to my my device menu speakers
virtual headphones select playback
device none of that
it's a faff it's not going to mess up
your discord
input outputs it's not going to make you
suffer through scrolling down it's a
minor issue i know but it's a it's so
frustrating when you just want to
listen to your speakers it only takes a
few seconds
and it means that i don't have to fiddle
with windows select
playback device nonsense it's not going
to mess up my
discord audio inputs or outputs just
turn the thing off
listen to my computer it's a small
feature
but i love it it fixes that pet peeve
for me
bless speaking of discord the microphone
that's included is discord certified
now it's not going to blow your socks
off when it comes to audio quality
but it's got enough gain it's got enough
noise cancellation that doesn't pick up
my clicky clacky keyboard
and most importantly it's clear enough
that i can make effective enemy call
outs when playing escape from tarkov
or deliver my well-rehearsed speech as
to why i'm in fact
not the imposter while playing among us
with friends
the overall sound quality of these has
been pretty great they do come out of
the box pretty level
across the board maybe if not a touch
heavy on the bass but if you're like me
you like a bassier experience when it
comes to your games and music
then they're likely going to be ideal if
you do want to tailor
your audio experience a bit more steel
series has its own software with
an equalizer so you can really tailor
the audio experience to suit your tastes
the axis nines also come with dts
headphones 2.0
which is meant to simulate that kind of
surround sound
vibe inside your headphones now for me
and the games i play it's completely
fine i've not noticed a
huge uptick in me being able to pinpoint
enemy locations or
really know which angle gunfire is
coming from but
from what i'm aware in the sevens it was
an optionable
toggleable thing in the software now it
seems like a small
step back keeping it enabled all the
time i've looked in the software
and i can't find the option to turn it
off so
it's it's not a hugely intrusive feature
but it's a shame that you don't have the
option to play around with it
and flick it on and off you also have
the on-the-fly game to avoid
mix controls so with a little turn of
this wheel you can turn your discord up
or your game up in relation to each
other
makes it world easy and you don't have
to tab out and fiddle with your levels
you just turn the wheel find something
that suits you and you're comfortable
with my only gripe with these controls
however is they are
exactly where your thumbs sit where you
put the headphone on or you take
off so pretty much every time i take the
headset
off or put it on i'm messing with the
levels that i might have been
happy with before or i'll rejoin a
discord call after
go and get a parcel or go to the
bathroom or whatever
and all of a sudden i can't hear
anything and i have to spend like 20
seconds just
oh well i can hear you again yep oh no
hang on
oh they left the call with these minor
gripes aside though this thing does
everything i want it to music movies
games let me sit on the toilet without
audio interruptions
dude what the hell
all that coupled with a 20 hour battery
life
as well as being able to use these on my
ps4 and steelseries
have said that they will work on the
upcoming ps5 that is the whole feature
set
except for the chat to game
volume mixer i've got to say
me and my large head we couldn't be
that much happier oh but before i go
this one thing on the box really made me
laugh
the box says
pros have won more prize money with
steel series than any other brand
i good for them
i mean i'm not gonna win no money i'm a
bit of a scrub but
hey steel series i respect the weird
flex
but for nearly a week of me using these
things
those are my thoughts let me know if you
have any other questions about these
in the comments section down below or if
you want us to take a look at any other
bit of tech
or hardware then feel free to let me
know on twitter as well
until next time if you want to stay
tuned for all the tech news hardware
reviews pc gaming
and everything in between make sure you
subscribe to gamespot
you